je suis français
wyatt wama
[Musique]
ce qui veut tout
tout le monde me regarde à travers mon
innocence je pense qu'il me forme
la maîtresse d'école m'a dit que j'étais
chez moi mais mon papa lui pourtant se
méfie d'elle était fidèle
la france est belle mais même regarder
ou comme la tour eiffel
mes parents m'ont pas mis au monde pour
toucher les ailes
j'ai vu que marion madoui t'es quoi elle
se mêle
je suis français
tu te trouves autres enfants c'est la
cas merci d'être là mon chéri tu es
vraiment aussi merci ça veut dire un
truc bien ça veut dire quoi alors black
m j'aime le black
[Rires]
j'adore est ce que je viens de voir
booba liste aux dires le sosie de booba
en train de manger un banni ce taux
cette fois c'est bh que j'ai vu date jus
d'orange
ces dates jus qui boit un jus d'orange
pressé ou est ce que j'ai vu blackman m
aaa c'est-à-dire black m avec un
personnage amène m à votre avis la
grippe même déjà c'est sûr que non parce
que je suis en train de lui parler
actuellement la promesse alors c'est le
sosie de booba oui je pensais que ses
amis avaient choisi le choisi booba
ouais non pas des jo on va regarder
toile et chaussées une banale son parti
qui soulagera le rideau blaquart
[Applaudissements]
tous
sa maman star
je suis français
ve
[Musique]
ce qu'il veut trouver
juste black amy a un truc qui ressort
c'est tout le monde dit mais tu danses
hyper bien faire est donc libre alors
mais tu fait le moonwalk
c'est un truc de ouf
[Applaudissements]
j'entends passe pas tout
[Musique]
bien vite te voir frère m'a dit bonjour
un calage criminelle non j'ai pas eu
cette chance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis français
[Musique]
je suis
ben simon
m
des ados
je suis
tu la connais très bien que je ne
connais pas très bien mais je pense
qu'elle a regardé ça veut dire ça va tu
la connais très bien
ah oui ça va arrêter de croire qu est
toujours au guichet la roche mais non
roche évalue
[Musique]
je
je suis peur je suis jaune je suis blanc
je suis un être humain comme toi je suis
chez moi on est tous france
hier d'abus
monsieur diallo
[Musique]
vas-y